e
for
e e
[Music]
yeah e
all
right good evening table people welcome
we're so thankful that you're with us
tonight um I don't often get the
opportunity to be the person who says
welcome and invites you into this space
but wherever you came from if this is
your first time or your 100th time or if
you're joining us online thank you thank
you for being here because your presence
makes such an impact and such a
difference and it's really a privilege
to us to have this space that we share
together um I am up here because as my
shirt demonstrates this weekend our K
children's ministry team ran our summer
ramama event that we do every year and
it is like a two-day um like a summer
camp you know VBS type event and this
year our theme was um carry the torch
for um the upcoming Summer Olympics in
Paris so um we talked all about the
Light of Christ and Shining our light
and we have some kids here that are
going to demonstrate for you guys one of
the um songs that we learned together
but I just wanted to say as they come up
here that um we also use this event as
sort of the transition point for some of
our sixth graders who are graduating out
of kids ministry and moving on to
seventh grade as teenagers
and this is sort of their last Terra in
kids ministry and so we wanted to name
that with you guys not only to
congratulate them for their you know
upcoming change into middle school but
also because that means you'll be seeing
them in this space more and you might be
seeing them as volunteers serving in a
kids classroom with an adult um and we
just wanted you to be people are like
okay Anna it's all right she's losing
her sixth graders
um but yeah y'all can come for Anna
later she's not sure about this she's
not
ready but anyways um but if you guys
would just help us to make them feel
welcome in this space on Sunday nights
and also as they um get the opportunity
to volunteer and serve in kids
classrooms as helpers so we're excited
about that and they're um they did a
great job this weekend helping lead some
of the songs and the dances so could you
guys come come on up here and we're
going to demonstrate for everybody and
leaders if you were here serving adults
you're welcome to do this dance with us
if you got it come show your stuff this
is our moment to shine guys that was our
whole theme was shine your light come on
up
everybody and as they're coming I do
want to say that if there's adults not
here tonight that we're at suama it's
because they are so you could yeah
please come because they are so so very
exhausted if you if you showed up
tonight after being here all weekend and
serving high five to you we're so
grateful but y'all there was a team how
many adult volunteers do we have Anna do
we have a count on
that 17 different adult volunteers
volunteering and helping all weekend
long and I mean from everything from
like you know taking care of boo boos to
doing arts and crafts and sports and
water slides and the whole nine yards so
we thank you adults from the bottom of
our heart for what you gave to our kids
this week okay guys let's spread out
some of y'all come over here so we have
a little bit more room and Caitlyn's
going to help us out in the back and
with the sound team and we're going to
do our song are y'all ready sixth
graders y'all got to help them out okay
show them how to do
it all right
[Music]
in the world it's lost its way we're
going to lift up Jesus name we're going
to share the truth we know that Our God
Saves so everybody
shouted and everybody lift your hands
we're going to spin around and celebrate
what we done
we going to shine your light into the
darkest night we're going to shine the
light the light of
[Music]
Jesus we going to shine your light and
we will not hide we going to shine the
light the light of
Jesus set about in us today and we will
never be the same sa we going to share
the truth we know that Our God
Saves so everybody shout
it and everybody lift your hands we're
going to spin around and celebrate what
we
F we will shine your light into the
darkest night we going Shine the Light
the light of Jesus
Shine Your Light and we will not hide we
going to shine the light the light of
Jesus woah
wo we won't hide in enough we will let
it show and Shine for you we Shine for
you oh so this world can say the love it
set us free we shine oh you we
shine we're going to shine your light
into the darkest night we're going to
shine the light the light of Jesus
[Music]
W you sh
your light into the darkest night we're
going to shine the light the light
Jesus we going Shine Your Light and we
will not hide we going Shine the Light
Light of Jesus wo wo wo wo
[Music]
hello everybody um I just want to thank
y'all one more time to the volunteers if
you are here thank you so much if you
are online and you're a volunteer thank
you so much we appreciate you and I hope
you are getting much need did rest from
this
weekend um and if summerama wasn't crazy
enough to add to our schedule we have
decided to add another event this
Saturday night at
7:30 um Kelly and Josh Tilford were kind
enough to open up their house to us for
a family movie night and we would
absolutely love to see you and your
family there we are going to have an
outdoor movie on a gigantic screen
um and we would just love to see you and
your kiddos there even if you don't have
kiddos you're still a family come on we
want to have you there bring your own
meal bring chairs to sit on the lawn or
blankets and drinks and it's just going
to be a great night we are going to be
watching Lion King 2 Simba's Pride the
best one if you ask me um and we are so
so excited to have you there so we hope
to see you there on Saturday at 7:30 and
there's more information information on
our social media page um
kiddos at this time you can go to your
class
okay thank you Anna and thank you kids
ministry um all right will you guys
stand with us we are going to make a a
holy shift a holy shift out of the
kingdom of noise into a holy moment
here e
cuz he's never let me down he's faithful
through
generations so I would hear he fa
now he
won't no he won't no he
won't i' still got joy in
[Music]
chaos I've got peace that makes no sense
so I won't be
going
day I'm not held by my own St cuz I
build my life on
Jesus oh he's never let me down he's
faithful in every
season so why would he fail
now he
won he w
oh he won't
fail he won't
fail he
[Applause]
[Music]
won he
W he won't
fail he won fail
Christ is my firm
foundation The Rock on which I stand
when everything around me is
shaken I've never been more glad I put
my faith in
Jesus cuz he's never let me down
faithful through
[Music]
generations so why would he will
now he
won't he
won't he won't
fail he won't
fail he you
[Music]
all came
wind but my house was built on
you I
safe with you
I'm going to make
it sing that again
rain
wind my house was built on
you and I'm safe with you I'm going to
make
it rain came when
my house was built on
you I'm safe with you I'm going to make
it
through and I'm going to make it
through cuz I'm standing strong on
you and I'm going to make it through
cuz my house was built on
you and I'm going to make it
through cuz I'm standing strong on
through cuz my house was built on you
Matthew
7 therefore everyone who hears these
words of mine and puts them into
practice is like a wise man who built
his house on the rock the rains came
down the streams Rose and the winds blew
and beat against that house yet it did
not fall because it had its foundation
on the rock
[Music]
and as I
Rise strength of
God go
before Lift Me Up
[Music]
as a
wake Eyes Of
God look
upon be my
[Music]
side
yeah as a way
Heart Of
God
satisfy and
suain as I
[Music]
hear voice of
God lead me
on be my
guide be my
[Music]
guide above it and below me before and
behind me in every eye that sees me
Christ be all around me above and below
me before and behind me in every eye
that sees me Christ be all around me
[Music]
and as I
go hand of
God my
defense by my
side as a
r Breath of
God fall
upon bring me
peace bring me peace
[Music]
above and below me before and behind me
in every eye that sees me Christ be all
around me above and below me before and
behind me in every eye that sees me
Christ be all around me
wo
wo Christ be all around
me
[Music]
wo
wo Christ be all around me
[Music]
and your life you're dead your blood was
shed for every
moment every moment your life you're
dead your blood was shed for
every
moment every moment your life life your
dead your blood was shed for
every
moment every sing it one more time your
life your death your blood was shed for
every
moment every
[Music]
moment above
and below me before and behind me in
every eye that sees me Christ be all
around me above and below me before and
behind me in every eye that sees me
Christ be all around
me wo
wo Christ be all around
me yeah
[Music]
wo
wo Christ be all around me above and
below me before and behind me in every
ey that sees me Christ be all around me
above and below me before and behind me
in every eye that sees me Christ be all
around
[Music]
me r
wind my house was buil on
you I'm safe with
you I'm going to make
it I'm going to make it
through cuz I'm standing strong on
you I'm going to make it
through cuz my house is buil on
[Music]
you God let us hear your words let us
put them into
practice let us build our life up found
upon your
foundation Upon Your Truth
God that you are
[Music]
love that you are up to good in our
lives that you will finish what you've
started that you will never let us
[Music]
go that you died so that we may have
life and have it abundantly
God we stand on that Foundation
tonight let us build upon
it in Jesus name
amen thank you guys if y'all want to say
hello to the people around you then
Brett will get us started on our message
well Grace and
peace it is good to be with you all
welcome welcome welcome to the table and
uh that includes those joining us on the
line y'all are not forgotten and uh
anyone here tonight uh who is new thanks
for for being here so um my name is
Brett pronounce he him and um we are
let's see we're kind of starting to come
towards the end of the series so next
week will be the last message in uh in
our series that we're in right
now
e e
confused and think this is a sermon
about those things specifically or that
that's the only things I have kind of in
mind here that's why I titled it the
virtual it's uh a much broader theme
here I'm thinking of you know really
just digital living in general is is
really what I have on the right just for
the sake of time though I need to like
zero in a little bit and um you know I
can't like cover all the data on all all
the things so we're just kind of honing
in a little bit so um all right so let
me run you through some of this data
social media and specifically I'm going
to focus on its impact on teens
especially on teen girls this data is
getting more and more out there so maybe
this is like super old news to um all of
you um but maybe not we got some teen
girls in the house they're like no like
yeah sorry not sorry all right so here's
some data 95% of teens age 13 to 17 use
social media apps thinking here Tik Tok
Instagram you know Etc which is a
remarkable number honestly if you just
asked me up front like what's the number
guess it I'd been like I think probably
in the 80s you know that would have been
my guess I knew it was high but
95% this is incredible um adolescent who
use social media more than 3 hours per
day face twice the risk of experiencing
poor mental health
outcomes anxiety depression self har
suicidal ideation Etc uh which is that's
that's a profound thing now this is tied
though to the next point which is that a
recent survey found that e and 10th
grade students spend an average of three
and a half hours per day on these
platforms can you see the connection and
the challenge here right so we've got at
the 3-hour Mark we've got some major
issues kicking in
and then the average user though is
around three and a half which means of
course some are less but many are you
know much more than that uh and as we'll
see in just a moment some of the well in
fact let's get to that so there's um you
can throw up that first image that's the
chart this is the UK teens um so a few
things to kind of note here first um
you'll notice girls are much more
susceptible to this then boys there's
like various kind of sociological
reasons for that we won't go into it now
um but you can see those numbers you
know um are are different however notice
even for boys at the so the bottom chart
you can see that's kind of usage you
know and as the usage increases that
it's a it's like a little plane taken
off
just and notice though even for boys at
the 2hour
Mark uh the same thing starts to uh
happen um where you get these kind of
mental health issues cropping up we have
the next uh slide is this is us teens
now this is specific to depression and
this isn't charting so much around age
but this is by
year so you can see kind of what we have
is around 2014 it's kind of you know
kind of average and then it just
starts sort of um increasing increasing
increasing so why is this if you need a
good authority on this Jonathan height
uh well actually his name will be up
there he's a really good research he's
done a lot of thinking and reflecting on
this and so I have a quote it's a
lengthy quote but I think it's worth um
kind of reading out in whole he says
this we are now 11 years into the
largest epidemic of Teen Mental Illness
on record as the cdc's recent report
showed most girls are suffering nearly a
third have seriously considered
suicide
a3d why is this happening why did it
start so suddenly around
2012 and then he's going to run through
various things that they've studied like
maybe it's this maybe it's this maybe
it's this maybe it's not because the
global financial crisis it's not because
the 911 attacks wars in the Middle East
or school shootings as Emil durkheim
showed long ago people in Western
societies don't kill themselves because
of wars or Collective threats they kill
themselves when they feel isolated and
alone also why would American tragedies
cause the epidemic to start at the same
time among Canadian and British girls
there is one giant obvious International
and gendered cause social media
Instagram was founded in 2010 the iPhone
4 was released in two that of course was
the first smartphone with a front-facing
camera in 2012 Facebook bought Instagram
and that's the year that its user base
exploded by 2015 it was becoming normal
for 12-year-old girls to spend hours
each day taking selfies editing selfies
posting them for friends enemies and
strangers to comment on while also
spending hours each day scrolling
through photos of other girls and
fabulously wealthy female celebrities
with seemingly vastly super your bodies
and lives the hours girls spent each day
on Instagram were taken from sleep
exercise and time with friends and
family what did we think would happen to
them it's uh I mean it's sobering isn't
it it's sobering but I think just better
to face these things you know kind of
face them and and start to figure out
what to what to do uh in in light of
them all right let's shift over to
smartphones because this kind of uh uh
isn't just teens um just in the same way
social media isn't isn't just teens but
this is more this is more for us this is
the the adults in the room this so um
average iPhone users they're on their
phone for two and a half hours per day
young adults now use their phones for
roughly 5 hours and 30 minutes per day
in the Western World the average user
checks their phone once every 6 minutes
and 30 seconds
I mean just I mean honestly I'm not
surprised at that at all I feel like it
could be every 3 minutes you know like
uh I mean how many of you have had even
the Phantom like if you keep your phone
on silent the Phantom Buzz or the the
you know the vibration like I think it
oh oh no nothing okay you know uh we're
just we're just primed for this now you
know I mean it's just I'm standing in
line well just get my phone you know
like I just it just it's always there uh
42% of people never turn their device is
off anywhere from 40 to 60% of adults
depending on the study say they are
addicted to their phones I love the
self-con fessional nature of that like
yeah I'm yeah that's me you know um of
course that 40 to 60% doesn't include
the other what I don't know 25% who are
like just delusional and not wanting to
self-report you they're like no no I
have a great a very healthy relationship
to my phone you know um and again this
isn't right I'm just honing in on social
media and and smartphones and such we
could keep going with all the other
forms of ways we live online and
interact online and you know um all of
that I mean I'm thinking from video
games virtual reality YouTube podcast
Netflix um I mean on and on it's just a
it's like a Cascade it's like a a
waterfall of the virtual and we're all
just sort of immersed in it and um I
want to name though my point here isn't
to demonize these things it's it's not
to say you know like oh if you have a
social media app on your phone you know
that's the devil or something um it's no
it's it it's more complicated much more
complicated than that um it just I think
maybe way to summarize it it feels to me
like there is some line and maybe the
line's a little bit different for each
of us but there's just some line that we
start to
cross
and either we start to suffer
or the people the relationships that
matter to us most begin to kind of
languish and we don't necessarily know
why you know
um it reminds me a little bit of Jesus
saying how he said the Sabbath day was
made for Humanity not not Humanity for
the Sabbath day of rest like in other
words the the the day of rest it was
there to serve human flourishing that
was the whole point but it kind of got
weird with kind of in religious minds
and suddenly it was almost like people
were there to serve
the institutional day of rest and make
sure you're doing that right you know
and it became this kind of heavy-handed
thing it's almost like that's sort of
the as a as a culture we kind of started
down this techn virtual digital road and
I think it was super well-intentioned
like let's try to make life better let's
try to make life more interesting and
you know all the thing okay great we
kind of go down that road but at some
point sline and it's like as as usage
goes
up goes down
um mental health goes down and this is
this is a I mean it's a real real issue
um but I just wonder if we're too
addicted to either notice it or stop
it and of course it goes beyond though
like statistics and data and bullet
points and you know studies and all that
like it's even just anecdotally I mean I
see a lot of heads nodding and such like
I think just for ourselves often we can
we kind of know like yeah something's I
don't know I I look back on how I lived
20 years ago with like a little bit of
nostalgia you know or something um I've
even heard recently there's this amazing
YouTube video kind of making I think I
linked to it an EET recently where um
it's like who was this was around early
2000s I think um maybe even no it was
like the 90s and someone had videoed
like a high school like last day of
school
thing and it's like you know just
homemade this guy and he's just randomly
interviewing people and it's like this
huge hit among like jiny people because
they're they're like whoa look at this
High School like like look they're all
like just hanging out like without
phones like look at that they're all
like in Little circles and they're just
like
talking like they they have nothing to
do except be with each other that's and
it's this like internet sensation like
millions of views and people like these
kids are like I find myself nostalgic
for a life I never had you know like
this is kind of you know where we are I
and I see it I see it in the eyes
sometimes of the teenager um who can
text with me you know but can't like
speak to me face to face you know I see
it um in the man I know not he doesn't
go here but a gentleman whose marriage
is is falling apart because of a gaming
addiction uh I I see it in there's a an
elderly gentleman in Wy whose little
mini apartment yard I service each week
it's like my for my side job it's like
my smallest yard I mean it's literally
like this that's the whole yard you know
um and every week though I go to his
house I've been there mostly on Fridays
but at times I've had to come different
days of the week for a while I was like
walking his dog and such so I was it
like Sundays randomly Tuesdays all sorts
of days doesn't matter when I
go every time he's there doing the same
thing he just sits in his recliner with
his dog and he's watching
TV and that's
it like all day every day it's just the
same and I and no judgment on him like
I'm I'm
thinking huh like at one level I'm not
shocked at all like yeah that's kind of
you know 21st century living but I'm
thinking what is up with our society
like where
how how did we get so isolated and alone
and and and
disconnected um and I think really it's
here as a pastor as a
Christian that I I kind of find myself
turning to the scriptures and
wondering like how can they speak to
this strange new
world like how can they they help St
Paul or or characters like Ruth and
Abraham and uh Sarah or Peter or John
and the other writers and characters
like honestly at times and ways they
feel so distant from this
world this world at least that I'm
living in like where is the verse about
smartphone
usage where is the text about the
dangers of of the digital life you know
or where's the the passage about Ai and
a life lived online that's like a whole
other thing you know um like honestly
they're they're not there at least not
explicitly right we're talking 2,000
years of cultural Gap like they
different
world um but this is where I am I'm
grateful I'm grateful for theologians
writers thinkers Christians who are
doing this bridging work I'm thinking of
folks like Sarah kley and Graham Ward
and and many hundreds of others uh who
are deeply rooted in the Christian
tradition and then they're they're kind
of reading and interpreting culture so
to speak all this STA and all sorts of
things to help do kind of bridge the gap
and something that they well something I
hear coming up with them over and over
and over again is the idea of
bodiliness meaning um like you are are
how do you phrase it it's weird to say
in a body or you are a body or you are
you know
embodied and um hang with me again
because I'm going to connect this back
to back to Tech in a few minutes but
just think of it like this we are
embodied creatures through
delves through our bodies like even our
words which can kind of seem to be
somehow disconnected from the body but
right everything you've been hearing
there's like it's up from vocal cords
and it it vibrates and it hits your ear
drums right there's a a bodiliness even
to this experience we are embodied
through and through and then just think
of Christ right the Son of God what what
did he do well John chapter 1 puts it
like this in the beginning
was the word the word means like the
logos or the Divine being God's son and
the Word was with God and the Word was
God he was with God in the beginning
through him all things were made without
him nothing was made that has been made
in him was life and that life was the
light of all humankind and the word
became what
flesh and made his dwelling Among Us you
see Christ the Divine being God's son
became
embodied this is what's known as the
Incarnation or the INF fleshman to
certain ancient Minds this would have
been quite a startling idea uh because
God who is pure Spirit right took on a
body lived a bodily
life so in a sense Christianity you
might say is a a a religion of
incarnation of INF fleshman of
embodyment and so some of what we all
kind of have to come to grips with is
the nature of our own bodily life like
anyone who has made love knows the
raptures of the bodily life anyone who
has been terribly sick knows the hell of
the bodily
life and and yet like nonetheless though
there is something good about it not
perfect but good about the body and as
it is with Jesus so it is with us all of
us are called to an incarnation of sorts
we are called to embrace our bodies you
see Christianity it is not about a
flight from this world of the body
Christan Christianity is about
Incarnation and
Transfiguration where we Embrace bodily
life and then have it healed and made
whole and this it seems to me is part of
the profound problem with the virtual
and the digital it is not about
Incarnation is it rather it's the
opposite it's about
excarnation or we might say dis
Incarnation it's actually a flight from
the body as I've named before just think
about what happens when you watch
television for like
hours or if you're on a computer for
hours and hours what happens you forget
you have
what a body it's like your mind you're
just kind of gone from the body
uh before kids I used to spend
ridiculous amounts of time watching
college football on Saturdays um I can't
do like quite this level but I used to
watch like sometimes I would watch all
three games if you know how long college
football games are they're so long so
like noon 3: 6 would end at 9: so like
nine hours of college football and uh I
it was entertaining it was but
afterwards I felt terrible
you ever had this experience like you
binge or something you know what I mean
you're just sitting in front of the
screen like hours and hours it was
almost like my body wanted revenge on me
for neglecting it you know I just was
like eating junk food and just kind of
sitting
there and it was it it I felt it in my
body you see this is what I'm driving at
our goal as Christians is not to become
excarnation but incarnated to inhabit
our material spiritual bodies as
profoundly and beautifully as we can in
other words we need to embrace life not
run from it like in a weird way what
what this um theology would name is that
like so much of bodily life is good and
therefore inherently
spiritual like just to live and be here
as yourself
present is
spiritual it it is religious in the best
sense of the word it is profoundly
connected to God and creation and other
people right this is it's it's it's
about
Incarnation so it's not Spirit verse
body but but the spirit in and through
and as body which means sometimes the
most spiritual thing you can do is
simply things where you are deeply
present in inhabiting your body to go on
a walk without a
phone and simply be present to the world
around you
creation to eat a meal with someone and
sip wine with them and like really be
there for that moment to recite
scripture to yourself over and over with
with the body to sing as we did earlier
right with the body it's it's this way
of coming home to
ourselves as I was maybe about halfway
through writing this message um a few
weeks back my daughter Eve is like
towards the beginning of summer so she
uh knocked on my door and she said hey
Dad uh can I go to firew wheel mall with
a
friend and I think I startled her
because I was like yes
yes you can godp speeed my daughter
go live live throw the phone here give
it to me in the trash can be liberated
go be free be free like do the thing I I
think it was I was thinking of that
video about the kids in high school and
like look they're all just hanging out
it's weird you know and I was thinking
like that's like it's this thing I just
taken for granted I just taken it for
granted they like oh of course teenagers
will connect and hang out and spend time
together face to face and
and I realized like no no not
necessarily you know we're just varing
micro does or something you know like
and I wanted to encourage her like yes
there's something beautiful and holy and
good about going to fir wheeel mall and
like spending time with people getting a
slushie a little bit on like a little
mustache little Sonic slushy mustache
where you don't even know it's there you
know like there's something good about
that that face-to-face real life
connection it's not just of like well
good for mental health I mean though it
is that right can you see I'm trying to
frame it in it it's much more important
than that it really comes back like back
to our own life and and our own sense of
connectedness to ourselves God and
others so to kind of summarize I we've
covered a lot here's just a few
takeaways if you're like a notetaker or
just want to remember something um the
data on social media especially among
teen girls ages 13 to 17 it is Bleak so
parents you know do with that what you
will uh be thinking through what this
means for your teens um if your mental
health is declining take a good hard
look at how Digital Life may be crowding
out sleep exercise and face-to-face
connection with others um because again
a lot of it is time you know it's not
like if I I check Facebook per day you
know once per day okay it's not it's
it's really about how this starts to
creep and take over um other things thir
digital living pulls us towards
excarnation other words being lost in
thought forgetting we have a body rather
than incarnation in Embrace of bodily
life in the real world for becoming like
Jesus is the process of learning to
inhabit our bodies
well this good spiritual practice things
like reciting scripture silence nature
walk small groups is the opposite of
digital practice in that it helps us
sink deeply into bodily life so in
closing bodily life it isn't uh it is
isn't perfect but it is blessed by God
and it is good oh so very good so let's
make this holy shift from the
excarnation the dis incarnation of
Digital Life and let's move towards the
Incarnation of bodily life in the name
of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit
amen so as we come to the table of the
Lord tonight as we take in the body of
Christ in the bread the blood of Christ
in the wine may it be a moment of well a
holy moment a holy embodied moment where
you come forward and and taste and see
and smell and hear it's it's a very um
tactile and bodily thing we are doing as
we come forward to connect with God in
this way so um I invite you to to Really
enter into silence enter into the
experience of this so the way we're um
going to do this we'll just go Um form a
line here and we'll just go row by row
starting here from the front and working
our way backwards we practice what's
called an Open Table meaning if you're
here tonight and you'd like to
participate then you are free to do that
regardless of your exact theology or
denomination or something to that effect
um you should know the red is wine the
white is grape Juans juice so for all of
our sixth graders who are moving up all
don't sneak that red
wine and finally you can um just partake
whenever whenever and however you'd like
some folks like to kneel some folks like
to return to their seats however you'd
like to do it so this is the table not
of the church but of the Lord It's Made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here
long you who have tried to follow and
you who
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
we're going to close tonight um with a
hym that I just just love so much and
has really spoken to me this week um but
it also reminded me of a verse and funny
enough um a friend of mine you guys many
of you know Raymond Lester was texting
us earlier this week and um referred
back to this verse and I went and read
it and it's just been such a gift and so
in line with sort of the push for us to
live incarnated in our bodies so I'm
going to read that real quickly and then
you guys um if you'd like to stand and
sing with us this final hymn this is
from acts 17 from one man he made every
nation of men that they should inhabit
the whole earth and he determined the
times set for them and the exact places
where they should live God did this so
that men would seek Him and perhaps
reach out for him and find him though he
is not far from each one of us for in
him we live live and we move and we have
our
[Music]
being this is my
father's
world into my
leing
ear all nature seeing
and round me brings the
music of the
swe This Is My Father's
World
Hest me in the
thought of rocks and trees of skies and
sea
he hand the
wers
[Music]
RO this is my
mother's
world the birds their
cars
race the
Morning Light the
Lily White
declare their
makers
praise this is my
mother's
heart she shines in all that's
well the
rustling grass I hear her pass she
speaks to me
everywhere This Is My
Father's
World oh let me never
foret and though the wrong seems are so
strong God is the RO
[Music]
and though the wrong
seems so strong God is the
ruler This Is My Father's
World why should my heart be said
the Lord is King let the
heavens R god reigns let the Earth be
glad the Lord is
King let
Heavens
ring God R let the Earth
[Music]
be since I wasn't able to introduce
myself at the beginning for those that I
haven't met my name is Miriam um want to
thank all of y'all for being here
everyone online um if you're a visitor
feel free to scan the QR code that is
should be popping up there we go um fill
out some info there's also some cards on
the table over there and this is just
for us to get to know you um offer up
you know any prayers any sort of
anything we can do for you or answer any
questions for
[Music]
you got mixed up sorry uh speaking of
prayer if you are in need of any prayer
I encourage you you know come find me
after service if you're in need of a hug
a high five just maybe words of
encouragement maybe you're going through
you know some a hard time and you just
need someone to talk to I'm happy to
lend an ear and to talk you through
that for us to be here as a church and
for us to operate a lot of that has to
do with giving from our members and so I
do encourage you if you feel led to give
go ahead and scan that QR code as well
again it's over there on the table just
an example I set up a recurring payment
every month it's something I don't you
know
if I if I tend to forget if life gets
busy hustle and bustle I know that it's
coming out and I'm not missing that and
you know if you have any questions on
Where does that go and what what do we
fund with that and what do we do with
that we'd be happy to answer that for
you as
well so feel free to stay seated if you
would like to stand I'm going to send us
out with a benediction um you know you
can stand in a posture of receiving you
can just open your heart and hear these
words let them flow through you
and more than anything I hope this gives
you encouragement throughout the week
this
week you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
this is especially true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with this yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between go filled
with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
the way that you are and go filled with
God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same Gifts of Love Grace
and unconditional um I'm sorry an
unconditional love to everybody that you
come in contact with be blessed we hope
to see you all next Sunday thank
you this is my father Father's
World why should my heart be
said the Lord is King the heaven re god
reigns let the Earth be
glad the Lord is King let the heavens
[Music]
R God RS let the Earth be CL
hey hey hey
[Music]
hey
yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
he
oh oh